So now that we've looked specifically at Donald
Trump's press briefing, comments about the
horrifying Atlantic story, which has now been
quadruply corroborated by the AP, Fox News
and CNN, there is a ton of other material
from this weird press briefing that I want
to go over, especially because Kamala Harris,
in her interview on CNN, which we looked at,
discusses a lot of the material from this
press briefing.
So this first clip, this is just incoherent.
I don't know what Trump is saying here.
Can you figure out what he's talking about?
Now, they want to stop regulations.
They want to bring up regulations to a level
stop the things that we're doing, which are
a much smaller level, and bring up regulations
at a level that nobody's ever seen before.
They want to do.
I beg you, try to figure out what Donald Trump
is talking about there.
Donald Trump then absurdly claims that economic
shut downs to combat the virus kill more people
than the virus itself.
Now, I'm going to deal with the numbers in
a moment.
First, take a look at what Trump said.
Want to abolish American energy?
I mean, that's what's going to happen, adopt
disastrous trade deals and inflict a devastating
shutdown.
As you know, he said, we want to shut it down.
We would be willing to shut it down.
And you don't shut down when we're setting
records.
And by the way, we're rounding the corner.
We're rounding the corner from the virus.
Joe Biden's blanket shut down would collapse.
Our economy would cause countless deaths from
suicide, drug alcohol abuse, heart disease
and more.
You know, shut downs caused a lot of problems,
a lot of very serious problems, more so than
the virus itself.
So we're approaching 200000 deaths from Corona
virus.
The shut downs have obviously not caused.
200000 deaths are anywhere close to it.
Now, let's be thorough.
Our deaths of despair a thing.
Yes, of course.
We've reported on that on this program.
They've been a problem in the United States
for economic reasons for a long time.
Deaths of despair are a real thing.
Can later diagnoses of cancer, for example,
or other conditions because people are opting
out of going to the doctor right now?
Can that lead to premature death?
Of course it can.
Of course, Ken, being in quarantine cause
somebody to commit suicide.
It could happen, but we've had two hundred
thousand Corona virus deaths.
It's insulting to suggest that that is not
as bad as the number of deaths we've had due
to the shut downs.
It's ludicrous and it's laughable.
Then Donald Trump again suggests this idea
that states that are closed are closed for
political reasons to hurt him and that the
day after the election they're all going to
open.
Take a look.
North Carolina.
I think that Michigan and Pennsylvania and
other states, they should open the governors.
A Democrat governor should open the states.
I'll open them on November 4th, but that should
open.
It's very unfair to the people to have those
shutdowns continuing at the level that they're
continuing.
Democrats are insisting on the shutdowns.
Two things on this.
Number one, the shutdowns aren't really continuing.
I mean, to different degrees.
Even Massachusetts, which is being very careful
and there's like sort of limited indoor dining,
not every restaurant's doing it.
A lot of colleges are going remote.
There's really don't know for shutdowns going
on at this point in time.
And of course, the shutdowns were not done
for political reasons.
No governor is on November 4th going to say,
hey, we can now open wide open now, but we
can now open wide.
That's another Trump fantasy.
It's not going to happen.
Then Trump spoke about the vaccine.
Again, this is tracking with a lot of what
Kamala Harris talked about in her interview
with CNN. Trump says we can probably have
the vaccine during October.
And you might have noticed that Trump's timeline
for the vaccine keeps getting pushed up more
and more, percent more.
Greater access mortality than the United States.
A lot of you don't want to report that.
And if we took New York and out of the equation
is nobody even close to a job we've done is
incredible and we don't get any credit for
it.
But we've done an incredible job through Operation
Warp Speed with three vaccines in the final
stage of clinical trials.
Yesterday, Pfizer announced.
I just spoke to the head of Pfizer, cret guy.
They announced that it expects to have the
results of its trial very, very shortly next
month.
But very shortly, we remain on track to deliver
a vaccine before the end of the year and maybe
even before November 1st.
We think we could probably have it sometime
during the month of October.
And Pfizer is among the leaders.
As you know, Carmela was asked, would you
trust the vaccine that a Trump FDA approves
in October?
And she said, I don't trust Trump.
And it is not about anti vaccine.
It's about Trump being the constant liar then.
And this is just wild Trump on social distancing.
Listen to this and I'll tell you why it's
crazy in a moment.
And we need everybody to be careful to apply
common sense and do all of the things that
we've told you to do as quickly as much as
you can.
Social distancing, wearing a mask when ever
the distancing is not possible and staying
like saying with a group that, you know, let's
just try and get through this one weekend.
And I think we have a chance of doing that.
Just social distance, wash your hands.
All of the hygiene things that we speak about
and we're really rounding the turn.
So Trump says that.
But Trump is doing rallies.
Trump just did a rally in Latrobe, Pennsylvania.
Everybody's standing together.
No masks.
Huge crowd, no Kovik tests, no hand washing.
Everybody crammed into a tight space to wait
for Donald Trump to show up.
He's saying at press briefings, mask space
between people, all this stuff, and then he's
holding optional events where it is impossible
to do it.
Lastly, Trump or a couple more clips.
Trump can't Andrew.
Understand the English of the same Indian
reporter who's been there for years with the
press corps.
Trump tells him he didn't catch anything other
than India.
Thank you, Mr. President.
The conventions.
Thank you.
Conventions, Kimberly and Dawn Judy are having
outfits that continuity with a video card.
Can't for more heels for you.
Which has gone viral among the battleground
states.
So my question is, Kimberly Vaughn.
Giuliani was very popular among Americans,
would be campaigning on their behalf.
Get your viewers like Yanguas.
Why, I didn't understand everything you said.
I know India.
Trump only understood India.
There you go.
And then the reporter tries again, and all
Trump can say is he likes India and they like
him in India.
And India is a very big country.
Some Americans do think he would do for you.
What do you do?
Well, we had a an event in Houston, as you
know, and it was a fantastic event.
I was invited by Prime Minister Modi.
And this was a massive.
This was at the where they play football Euston
football team.
And it was it was it was incredible.
It was actually incredible.
And the prime minister could not have been
more generous.
We have great support from India.
We have great support from Prime Minister
Modi.
And I would think that the people, Indian
people, would be voting for Trump.
I also, as you know, went to India just prior
to the pandemic setting in because India has
been hit very hard, left really about a week
before that.
And we had an incredible time.
What what we saw, the people are so incredible.
It's really an incredible place, an incredible
country.
And it's definitely big.
It's definitely big.
Trump also adds in that if the Indian people
were given the opportunity, they would they
would vote Trump.
This is indistinguishable from parody.
This is impossible to satirize.
What does.
How does SNL make a parody of a press briefing
like that?
We cannot withstand much more of this.
We really can't.
We have to remove this guy.